pour ceux qui viennent de nous retrouver
gérer mais qu'est ce que vous dites sur
le programme erasmus est bien le
programme erasmus donc on va repartir de
l'auberge espagnole away avant le film
ses étudiants qui arrivent en fait ça
permet de montrer que l'europe permet de
justement tous tous ces échanges en fait
faut savoir que les programmes erasmus
ont été créés grâce à l'europe
et ça vous aura pas échappé on a
quelques semaines d'un scrutin très
important qui va permettre à tous les
citoyens de voter pour ses représentants
au parlement européen
donc ça permet de voir avec erasmus et
bien que l'europe n'est pas là que pour
pondre des normes parfois un petit peu
abusive ou un petit peu décrié décrié on
va dire pour rester gentil mais non en
fait l'europe permet aussi et même avant
tout de créer du lien entre les citoyens
donc erasmus permet de faire de
nouvelles rencontres
exactement et des nouvelles rencontres
très intéressantes puisque ça permet de
rencontrer des personnes un pays
étranger rencontré une nouvelle culture
rencontrer des nouvelles méthodes
d'enseignement
ça permet bien sûr d'avoir une ligne en
plus sur le cv faire des études à
l'étranger avoir un diplôme est ici
d'université étrangère ça prouve que on
aime aller à la découverte
on va essayer d'aller un petit peu plus
loin aussi pascal chez bien que c'est le
lundi matin mais on va essayer de forcer
un petit peu quand on est français on
est trop con qu'on va étudier à
l'étranger miliana ce coup on est
soi-même étrangers ce qui permet de se
confronter à la différence et finalement
s'aperçoit qu'erasmus et bien c'est un
peu une université de la tolérance ont
été importants parce que pour la culture
notamment pour la cuisine aussi fred
voilà pour la santé pourquoi pas il est
peut-être différentes méthodes pour se
sevrer je sais pas à travers l'europe
on va toutes ces petites étoiles ici un
désintérêt vous l'évoquiez
quelques secondes c'est parler aussi la
langue du pays ça c'est très très
important
dans les faits ce n'était pas aussi
simple que ça quand même non et je vais
encore revenir sur ce fameux film parce
que je décris vraiment quelle ambiance à
prisches l'auberge espagnole pour ce
qu'un petit peu de mal parce qu'on en
parle depuis tout à l'heure
voilà des bébés c'est vrai qu'ils
résument vraiment bien l'ambiance
d'erasmus donc pour résumer l'histoire
c'est des étudiants qui viennent de
plein de pays qui se retrouvent à
barcelone donc quand ils sont dans la
rue et évidemment ils parlent espagnol
quand ils sont dans en cours ils parlent
espagnol mais quand ils sont dans la
coloc et bien il parle anglais
c'est la langue internationale donc en
fait l'avantagent d'erasmus c'est que ça
permet à la fois de parler de la langue
du pays mais en plus de parler en
anglais en même temps donc en fait on
apprend de langue en une ce qui est
plutôt intéressant
d'accord ça c'est dans la théorie mais
dans la pratique je sais pas fred si
vous connaissez ou au clément le
programme erasmus vous connaissez oui au
moins ouais vous savez comment on peut
partir pour ce programme clément non ça
tombe bien
concrètement il faut d'abord est inscrit
à l'université soit bourgogne souhait de
franche comté il ya pas de soucis ou de
bourgogne franche comté ou de bourgogne
franche comté mais les deux sites sont
pas enfin bref bloqué on s'est un peu
plus plus compliqué de quoi là il faut
être inscrit il faut trouver une
université qui est partenaire avec
l'université d'où on est originaire donc
par exemple pour la bourgogne à 230 à
peu près universités ou établissements
supérieurs qui sont un partenariat avec
l'université de qu'on fait ça ah oui
c'est vraiment un programme qui est très
ancrée dans la culture bourguignonne et
rencontre est pour le coup
donc il faut être inscrit à voir un
établissement baky qui puisse
correspondre avec l'université de
bourgogne et il faut trouver ainsi que
l'équivalent c'est par exemple vous êtes
en licence 2 d'histoire et bien vous
pourrez intégrer une licence d'histoire
dans un autre pays d'accord commun de
temps on peut partir avec erasmus c'est
assez variable en gros c'est entre 3 et
12 mois par cycle un cycle universitaire
donc c'est la licence donc les trois
premières années mais ensuite c'est le
masters et ensuite c'est le dr a donc il
ya ces trois cycles et dans ces trois
cycles on peut partir de trois à douze
mois
donc comme ça je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais ça semble séduisant
franchement à
on se dit tiens moi j'ai envie je suis
peut-être un peu tard parce que c'est
pour les jeunes essentiellement il faut
être étudiant et on peut être étudiant
n'importe quel âge vous pouvez aller
vous inscrire pour la prochaine rentrée
bons plans très bien ça c'est plutôt
séduisant aussi mais concrètement il ya
beaucoup de bourillon et franc-comtois
qui participent à ce programme erasmus
il ya plus de bourguignons que de francs
comtois en fait à peu près 14 et
quelques pour cent des étudiants
inscrits université de bourgogne
participent au programme erasmus qui
représente à peu près cinq mille 5000
100 étudiants grosso modo alors qu'en
bourgogne alors qu'en franche-comté
pardon et bien ils sont à peu près 7% et
vu qu'il ya moins d'étudiants
franche-comté qu'en bourgogne donc la
part d'étudiants franc comtois est moins
importante erasmus ça veut dire quoi
erasmus et par rapport à erasme ce grand
philosophe et en surf européen
alors ça veut dire pire opran vous en
sortir mobilicity je te donne mon avis
c'est tellement je suis tellement
mauvais que voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on
appelle généralement erasmus chez vous
m'arrêtez si je me trompe pas programme
des changes finalement d'étudiants et
d'enseignants si on n'en a pas parlé
entre les universités les grandes écoles
européennes et les établissements
d'enseignement à travers le monde entier
c'est ça et ça permet même de faire des
fois des programmes de recherche communs
parce que quand ils sont aperçus qu'ils
sont rencontrés à l'université et
qu'ensuite ils continuent à travailler
sur le maine le même domaine et bien ils
peuvent travailler ensemble
tiens pour votre peine à tous vous savez
combien notre pays dans l'union
européenne au jour d'aujourd'hui je
parle pas du break 6 cas au jour
d'aujourd'hui 27 100 de réussite
ah oui alors ça fait 28 on a 28 mon
honneur à 27,6 fabre oui c'est plus
compliqué moi je pense qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui on va 28 voyez-vous 28
pays états membres ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on votera pour l'europe
adulé ou décrié qu'on aime ou qu'on
n'aime pas aller voter ce sera le
week-end du 25 26 mai évidemment